hey how's everybody doing today I have
several different announcements to make
so please excuse today's video it's
going to be kind of short but since all
of you don't follow me on Twitter I had
to put this in a video that way everyone
had a chance to hear at all if you've
been wondering why I haven't released
part 4 or the plot leaked discussion I
did with the dawn of Ice and Fire that's
because a good bit of that audio in part
4 and part 5 is very distorted so Don
Willy and I have been planning to record
it again so we're trying to reschedule
it when we both have time to record
together which is kind of tricky right
now since we both have a 9 to 5 type job
as well but hopefully we can get that
done within the next few days that way I
can get those out to you as soon as
possible
and thank you for your patience but also
at the end of this video I will be
announcing who won to give away for the
complete game of Thrones series on
blu-ray when don't worry if you didn't
win because I'm going to be announcing
what the next giveaway is - so stay
tuned for that now there is something I
do want to discuss with you about a few
characters that way this isn't just an
announcement video there has been a
relationship in this show that I have
been thinking about and how there could
potentially be a problem within that
relationship in the future this isn't
something that I necessarily believe is
going to happen but it could happen so I
want your opinion on this
let's start this off by talking about
torment and Brienne two great warriors
with the potential of being a power
couple that no one seems to be talking
about everyone wants to see John and
Danny get married or they want to see
John and Shawn to get married or even
Cersei and you're on which are all good
possibilities but let's be honest who
doesn't want to see torment and Brienne
hook up now I know someone you were
going to say what about Jaime Lannister
Brienne obviously loves Jaime which is
true she absolutely has love for Jaime
but you have to forget about Jaime right
now because he still has his head up
Circe's ass
and while Brienne has sworn to protect
Sansa brain is never really going to be
able to have a healthy relationship with
Jaime
unless she actually leaves the stars so
let's talk about brain and torment can
you imagine if they had a child
if Brienne and torment had a child
together it could potentially grow up to
be one of the greatest warriors the
Seven Kingdoms has ever seen now I don't
know about you but I fully support this
couple torment has definitely be given
Brienne those hungry eyes but as of
right now bran is definitely playing
hard to get but over time I think she
may start to warm up to him and even
soften up a bit I think there may be a
way brand could see torment in a very
different light and it actually involves
the Hound it might sound crazy but you
can't say it's impossible because we
have seen this show going crazy
directions before so just hear me out
the last time we saw Brandon the Hound
come in contact with each other they
damn near fought to the death bran beat
the [ __ ] out of the Hound so bad most
people thought he was dead
but now that the Hound is back and back
in action what is going to happen the
next time these two characters cross
paths again
Bryan is on her way back up north more
than likely going the Winterfell when
she learns that the battle was over and
the Starks I've reclaimed Winterfell the
hound and the Brotherhood without
banners are in the Riverlands and
they're going to be heading north too
and I think eventually the Hound and
Brienne are going to meet again could we
see another fight between the two we
know from spoilers that John torment and
the Hound will be together next season
at some point and they're going to go up
north but when they get back to
Winterfell in Brienne is back with
sahn's at Winterfell how do you see this
interaction
one down between the two and what is
Forman going to do about it because
everyone saw the way tormund looked at
bran
that looks like love at first sight to
me folks
what is poor man going to do if the
hound tries to attack brand do you think
he's just going to stand by and watch I
don't think so when John torment and the
Hound get back to Winterfell there's a
very good chance that the Hound is going
to want to avenge his loss to Brienne
but given the feelings torment has for
Brienne I think if he is around when the
Hound tries to fight Brienne we could
see one of the greatest fights of all
time between torment and the Hound how
crazy would that be to see torment in
the Hound fight to the death over
Brienne I know it probably sounds crazy
as [ __ ] but give me your thoughts anyway
do you think bran and the Hound will
fight again if they see each other and
if torment is there what do you see him
doing about it think about it fellas if
you were corpsman who is obviously
infatuated with bran what would you do
if someone tried to attack a girl in
your presence especially one that you
had some very strong feelings for I'd
like to think you would do something
about that also let me know if you guys
even like the idea of tormenting Breen
as a couple it's kind of hilarious but I
totally love it and support it what do
you think about these two becoming like
actually a power couple and maybe even
having a house of their own up in the
north and being one of those powerhouses
of the north
tormund could eventually end up with his
own house and if Jamie does die and
brand ends up as tormance girl and they
have children together they could become
one of those strong northern houses now
that the Karstarks and numbers could
potentially be gone let me know what you
think about this okay now it's time to
announce the giveaways I just want to
mention real quick yesterday was
actually my birthday so when any of you
be so kind and give this video a like
just to show me a little bit of support
and kind of a little birthday person
from you I would really appreciate that
thank you if you do so but first I want
to announce what the next giveaway is
yesterday I got two new things that I
want to give away to you for always
showing support to me in the channel and
given my videos a thumbs up which really
does help the channel when videos reach
a wider audience I picked up the game of
Thrones trivia game and also got the
world of Ice and Fire a book
so what I will do next month is pick two
winners at the same time the first
person who gets picked will get to
choose which one of these they want then
the second person that is picked gets
the other gift and I will do both of
those on the same day which I will
provide a link for for that giveaway in
my very next video so good luck to
everyone that participates in the new
giveaway now let's get on to the winner
of the Game of Thrones series keep in
mind this was randomly selected by gleam
but don't worry if you didn't win just
make sure you stick around so you can
try and win one of the other new things
that I got for the next one which will
be announced in March but anyway the
winner is Brendon Miller so congrats
Brendan and thank you for participating
just message me here on youtube or send
me a message on twitter that way I can
get your address and send this out to
you as soon as possible and thanks
everyone for always being so cool and
supportive I really do appreciate that
and I will see you guys down in the
comment section bye